welcome back a live look at the scene
here in cleveland at the cleveland
clinic
case western university president trump
joe biden will meet face to face for the
first time
just hours from now and the candidates
are sure to be courting suburban voters
tonight
winning that voting block could be key
to securing critical swing states
our very own martha mccallum sat down
with some suburban women here in ohio
take a look
and i'm i'm pretty decided this time
about who i want to vote for
[Music]
i'm choosing trump this time the single
thing i want to see the most
in this election is a return to
a sense of dignity and respect
among the people that we elect to do the
people's business
and in another key swing state
pennsylvania a new poll out
has joe biden leading president trump
among those suburban voters by
nine points overall you can see men
there giving the hat tip to
president trump by a couple points women
overwhelmingly for biden in that poll
uh greg where do you think the suburban
vote is i've heard you talk about the
the concern about violence in a lot of
these cities and what that means for
that vote
yeah i don't uh i don't believe polls
are news
and i i think it's just basically taking
the temperature
and you can take the temperature any
different way stop sighing who's ever
sighing at my answers
uh the media says that trump
is banking on fear and anxiety but it's
the voter
which voters can't speak their minds for
fear of retribution
it's trump voters so who is stirring up
the anxiety in fear
prominent democrats are the ones that
have been doing that and they know
and they and they do this little
extortion trick it's gonna get worse
under trump
so who is stoking fear this is a big
problem because there are two
okay there are two parties right now
there's a republican in the democratic
party
one is saying you cannot cooperate with
the other
it's not the republican party trump will
talk to anybody
we know that it's a democratic party
that is saying
we cannot cooperate them because it's a
moral decision
biden says that trump is evil they say
that trump voters are deplorable
what does this do for america the only
thing that holds people together
from killing each other is something
called cooperation
if you decide that you're no longer
going to cooperate with people and you
tell that
no wonder the streets are in chaos and
there's riot and there's
looting and that come november it's
going to get worse you have
a leadership telling people that that's
the way forward
do not cooperate with people you
disagree with
dana pennsylvania is a key state i was
just in southwestern pennsylvania and
talked to a
bunch of different voters including the
heads of the democratic parties in some
of those counties
and you know there's all this talk about
the hidden trump vote well these
democrats there
say they believe it because they have
democrats who will not say
that they support trump even though they
do so we don't know what
that means what that shift means but
it's something
well it's not just a key state it's the
keystone state um
so to speak it is critical for both of
those
um candidates to try to get it i think i
think president trump has had some
problems in the suburbs you saw it in
the 2018 midterms you're
seeing it in some of these polls here
greg could be right i mean maybe there's
plenty that are just saying i'm not
going to say it in fact brett stevens of
the new york times
wrote a column today that said meet a
secret and a shy trump voters a lesbian
woman who said that
coming out as a trump voter is even
harder than coming out as a lesbian okay
that's how hard it is for some people to
admit that they're going to vote for
trump so
that's there in the new york times for
everybody to see and i feel like some
democrats are trying to broadcast that
message loud and clear
but one thing you know there's all this
talk about the suburban vote and i know
there are a lot more suburban voters
than rural voters
but joe biden's problems with rural
voters
is probably even stronger than that of
president
trump's problems with suburban voters
that is a lock and i think this is all
part of a
political realignment that we are living
through and it's one of the reasons i
also believe president trump will try to
constantly turn back to the economy so
we can talk about what he accomplished
and also try to draw the contrast to say
if joe biden becomes your president this
recovery that we're currently in coming
out of the coronavirus recession
will stop and you will be in the back
where you were during the obama years
with everything stagnant and nothing
moving forward
juan in the debate tonight uh obviously
part of this is the fireworks that we're
going to see
but it's also talking to the american
people about what each presidency would
look like
right i think one of the real agendas
for both candidates is to give
the voters a sense of what their vision
is for the future
in the case of president trump what's
his agenda for a second term
or in the case of joe biden is he a man
that has
a vision of something more than just
being not donald trump
now i will say that in terms of this law
and order message that
president trump has been pushing it
doesn't seem to have moved the numbers
i mean so it seems like it's been a
waste of time and on the campaign trail
and a waste of ad money
and especially when you're talking about
suburban women and just to be direct
we're talking about white suburban women
so he has tried this not only in terms
of law and order but also in saying
i'm trying to push the fair button oh
your suburbs will be taken apart
you know that we're going to have more
middle-income housing minorities will
come in
to the people he calls housewives well
you know what it just hasn't worked it's
no
there's no evidence anywhere
pennsylvania or anywhere else
that suburban white women have said oh
gee i i'm thinking differently now
jesse bring it home here well i think
that waits to be seen what juan is
saying we'll find out on november 3rd
but the suburban vote is not monolithic
it's still the same rules apply
republicans vote republican democrats
vote democrat and independents are up
for grabs
it's really more about the education gap
the more advanced degrees you have
in the suburbs the more likely you are
to vote for joe biden
trump's competitive with college
educated and does very well
with high school diplomas he does very
well in the exers
you know the places kind of in between
the suburbs and the rural areas
and those areas are really undercounted
by pollsters
but trump is getting traction in the
suburbs on two major issues
people living in the suburbs are more
economically minded
they're definitely afraid of taxation
one of the reasons they're in the
suburbs
they're not living in the city and i
totally disagree with juan
they are very upset with this zoning
regulation where you can force
densely populated low-income housing
into your community and local
municipalities don't have a say about
that
this can no cash bail situation that
biden has signed on to with bernie
sanders
in the manifesto they're very against
that and they don't want the drugs
the crime and the gangs coming into
their communities